FOX TEAM COVERAGE.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE WITH MORE ON
THE HICKS APPEARANCE YESTERDAY
AND THE ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
WE BEGIN WITH CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS WITH
THE BREAKING NEWS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS LOSING HOPE.
THIS WHITE HOUSE AS THEY KNEW IT
WAS COMING.
>> I THINK HE IS LOSING HOPE IN
THE FORM OF A PERSON, NOT IN THE
FORM OF AN IDEA.
YOU MENTION ONE OF THE PEOPLE
CLOSEST TO THE PRESIDENT.
I WOULD SAY OTHER THAN THE
PRESIDENT'S IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
MELANIA, IVANKA, JARED KUSHNER,
HOPE IS PROBABLY CLOSEST TO HIM.
LITERALLY AT HIS SIDE FOR THE
PAST THREE YEARS WORKING
24 HOURS A DAY.
SHE WAS EMBROILED IN CONTROVERSY
NOT OF HER OWN MAKING WHEN THE
MAN SHE WAS DATING, ROB PORTER,
SUCCUMBED TO ALLEGATIONS OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE AND WAS TOLD TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE.
SHE TESTIFIED YESTERDAY FOR SOME
TEN HOURS BEFORE THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ABOUT
WHAT SHE KNEW ABOUT POTENTIAL
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
IN THAT TESTIMONY, SHE ADMITTED
TO AT TIMES TELLING "WHITE
LIES," ON BEHALF OF THE
PRESIDENT.
SHE DID SAY UNDER QUESTIONING
THAT NONE OF THOSE THINGS HAD
ANY KIND OF LAYERING ON THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION, AT LEAST
NO SUBSTANTIVE INVESTIGATION ON
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
STATEMENTS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
ONE OF THEM FROM HOPE HICKS
SAYING "THERE ARE NO WORDS TO
ADEQUATELY EXPOSE MY GRATITUDE
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I WISH THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION THE VERY BEST AS
HE CONTINUES TO LEAD OUR
COUNTRY."
FROM THE PRESIDENT: "HOPE IS
OUTSTANDING AND IT HAS DONE
GREAT WORK.
SHE IS AS SMART AND THOUGHTFUL
AS THEY COME, TRULY GREAT
PERSON.
I WILL MISS HAVING HER BY MY
SIDE BUT WHEN SHE APPROACHED ME
ABOUT PURSUING OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES I TOTALLY
UNDERSTOOD.
I AM SURE WILL WORK TOGETHER IN
THE FUTURE.
"WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS SAY SHE
HAS BEEN THINKING ABOUT LEAVING
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR SOME TIME.
WORKING AT A BREAKNECK PACE FOR
LONGER THAN MOST PEOPLE WOULD BE
ABLE TO.
SHE WILL ALSO STAY HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR MAYBE THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS.
HER DEPARTURE IS NOT IMMEDIATE
BUT IT'S IMMINENT.
>> Bret: STANDBY.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS INSISTING
THIS DOES NOT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE TESTIMONY ON CAPITOL HILL.
IT WAS NINE HOURS OF QUESTIONING
AND IT COMES AFTER SHE TALKED TO
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
AND HIS TEAM RECENTLY FOR A LOT
OF QUESTIONING.
>> ONE OF MY CONTACTS WHO'S BEEN
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION POINTED OUT HOPE
HICKS HAS BEEN BEATEN UP PRETTY
BADLY BY THE PROCESS.
HE POINTED TO THE INTERVIEW WITH
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL TEAM BUT
ALSO AN INTERVIEW WITH THE
SENATE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
AND MOST RECENTLY THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS FOR NINE HOURS WERE
SHE ANSWERED QUESTIONS GETTING
INTO A LOT OF SPECIFICS ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS AND MEETINGS DURING
THE CAMPAIGN AND ALSO THE
TRANSITION PERIOD.
HERE'S HOW REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS RESPONDED.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE PAUL
MANAFORT SITUATION?
>> PAUL MANAFORT WAS IN A
FEDERAL COURT THIS MORNING IN
WASHINGTON AND HE WAS RESPONDING
TO AN INDICTMENT, AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE COUNTS.
HE PLED NOT GUILTY.
IT WAS HIS FIRST COURT
APPEARANCE IS SINCE HIS BUSINESS
PARTNER RICK GATES GOT THE PLEA
AGREEMENT WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
MANAFORT IS LOOKING AT A TRIAL
DATE IN SEPTEMBER.
HE WAS ADMONISHED BY THE FEDERAL
JUDGE FOR RELEASING A STATEMENT
AT THE END OF LAST WEEK WHERE HE
SEEMED TO CHIDE GATES FOR NOT
BEING IN THE FIGHT FOR THE
LONG-TERM.
THERE IS A GAG ORDER FROM THAT
COURT FROM BOTH SIDES.
MANAFORT'S TEAM SAYS THEY ARE
GOING TO CONTEST IT.
>> Bret: JOHN, ABOUT THE
TURNOVER, THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LEFT IN THE FIRST 13
MONTHS, IT'S QUITE A FEW.
THOUGHTS FROM THIS WHITE HOUSE
ABOUT THE TURNOVER AND PERHAPS
THIS IS HIS CLOSEST CONFIDANT,
THE PERSON WHO WAS WITH HIM THE
LONGEST PERIOD >> IN MANY WAYS,
IN HIS RIGHT-HAND MAN.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE TURNOVER AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THERE IS A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POSITION OF
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR, IT'S
PROBABLY BEEN THE POSITION WITH
THE GREATEST TURNOVER.
SEAN SPICER WAS THE FIRST
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T FIND A
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR.
HE WAS PLAYING A DUAL ROLE OF
PRESS SECRETARY AND CALM
DIRECTOR.
THEN THEY BROUGHT IN DOUG AND
THEN SPICER WAS NAMED
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR AGAIN
AND THEN ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI WAS
BROUGHT IN FOR 11 DAYS AND THEN
HOPE HICKS WAS NAMED THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR.
I AM TOLD HOPE HICKS REALLY
WANTED TO LEAVE, SHE HAD BEEN
THINKING ABOUT IT.
SHE REALLY WANTED TO GET THE
TESTIMONY FOR THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE OUT OF
THE WAY.
BEFORE SHE MADE THE DECISION TO